I just I want you to train slow to try
to feel that uh back outward kazushi
between iag and
K when you can get the two techniques
that use the same kazushi pattern that
to feel exactly the
same then you're on your way for all the
techniques feeling the same then you're
on your way to reconciling form
okay so we'll just keep the two variants
that we
have we do
both
one
there
teach okay the two parts I'd like you to
focus
on is
um this part that brings her legs
forward do you
see it's again here
here not here bring her forward in the
[Music]
adhesion not here
forward there it
is
okay you feel that yes
okay here going slow I'd like you to
exaggerate that when you're going
quicker you don't always have to have
the legs going forward you'll always
have one if you're
standing but the
center has to be has to come forward
can't go stay there and then you from
there now go
backwards it has to go forward into the
kazushi that's enough do you see he
didn't I didn't exaggerate like with you
but it happened in terms of his Center
gravity
you see how the center comes
from not here and from where it is his
center of gravity you move it backwards
that's not
it so another
commonality is you you have your inward
spiral and if you were to reverse so
that SD me
nuget you
see you guys
see so you have your inward spiral and
if you were to reverse it and you keep
extending it you have your C hole you
have your outward spiral so the outward
spiral is just the reverse or the
inverse of the inward spiral it's the
same
technique so the spiral pattern is
exactly the same just one's going
forward one's going rearward or one's
winding in one's winding
out the other one is where your power is
so you it's not here where he's gripping
it it's in my elbow and in my and my
elbow is connected to my
quaw
qu
qu so you're doing e
n it's not your arm that's doing it your
the hand part is irrelevant
the elbow is doing it with my
qua grab I do the other one my elbow's
doing it with my
quad so I put this now in what I'm
trying to do but he's going
forward
forward in the qu is going to move you
see qu and the elbows connected to
it he's got to go
forward and then the qua St the cla's
going to move R and my elbow does the
throat
he has to go
forward P moves elbow
power B's going to move elbow power not
hand
power
not hand power okay let's go